leftist forces in all of america are
attempting to silence you
me all of us well my next guest knows
this all too well joining me now is
brandon strzok
founder of the walkaway campaign a
grassroots movement dedicated to helping
liberals walk away
from the democrat party brandon after
your group was given
the boot completely from facebook
this is the email that you say they sent
you pages that are hateful
threatening or obscene are not allowed
continued misuse of facebook's features
could result in the permanent loss of
your account
so what was hateful and threatening on
your page
brandon i guess they found us to be
threatening to the success of the
democrat party
i mean basically my page the only
content that goes on the walk away
campaign page
are testimonials true stories videos and
written testimonials coming from
people all across america and across the
world who have had enough of exactly the
type of behavior that we've been uh
seeing from social media in the last
couple days not to mention
uh from the liberal media not to mention
from the extremist behaviors of the
democrat party
pushing more fringe more left more
socialism more globalism
uh more extremity i mean that this is
what they're walking away from
but this is the only content that goes
on my page are these testimonials these
are people telling their stories so
there would never be any opportunity for
anyone to
uh glorify breaking into the capitol
building or glorify an act of violence
because people are just
talking about why they want to leave the
left so it was uh it was pretty scary
today when we woke up and we found that
our group had been shut down
every one of my employees i have about a
dozen paid employees they've
they've all been banned my volunteers
have been banned so brandon hold on hold
on
brandon where are you going to go
because now apple is threatening to
remove
parlor from the apple app store
meaning you're not getting parlor either
at least on apple google play looks like
the same thing
so where are you going to go well we're
so we're
we're rebuilding right now on
cloudhub.com which is a conservative
owned social media platform similar to
facebook
i want to encourage everybody in your
audience right now to go immediately to
cloudhub.com and sign up
and can you spell that please uh brandon
that's cloud c-l-o-u-t-hub
h-ub clout hub.com
and they have an app which you can uh
load in the app store as well
uh but the walkway campaign group is now
we're starting we're rebuilding from
scratch uh so that please join our group
uh help us out there this is really it's
really damaging laura i mean because the
people who lost their who got
my employees who got banned some of them
are merch managers some of them are
videographers they have other businesses
besides working with me now they can't
do their business yeah brandon
the left doesn't care they want total
control
no questions asked sit down shut up get
locked in
and no you know that's it for you they
don't they don't want to debate they
don't want a conversation they want you
silence period it's a lot like the ccp
if you ask me but the ccp's
their their outlets still get somehow
heard in the united states
media platforms brandon thank you so
much